what we have here are a few data
analysis questions in a biology context
from the new york regents exam but these
are useful example problems if you're
studying high school biology in general
because they might show up in some type
of an exam that your teacher gives you
or you might see on a standardized test
a student proposes that if volunteers
warm up before squeezing a clothespin
for one minute they will increase the
number of times that they can squeeze it
without tiring
he states that this is because their
muscles will be better prepared for the
exercise
the data from an experiment are shown in
the data table below
which trial from the chart above
provides the best data to support his
claim support your answer so pause this
video and see if you could answer it
so let's just make sure we understand
what's going on here so there's two
trials
this is the first trial trial one right
over here and in trial one you had two
groups
of 10 students
one of them did warm up and the other
ones and the other 10 did not warm up
and then in trial two you had two more
groups and this time there were groups
of 25 once again 25 who did warm up and
25 who didn't warm up
now in trial one the group that warmed
up actually had a lower number of
average squeezes so this goes against
the hypothesis that the student had the
hypothesis the student had is if they
warm up
beforehand then you'd actually be able
to do more squeezes so trial one
actually goes against the student's
claim
trial two
seems to slightly go in favor of the
student's claim the group that warmed up
was able to eke out a few more now we
haven't done the statistical analysis to
know if how probable this is if it was
due purely to random chance but just to
answer that question
one the data goes trial one goes a
little bit against the student's claim
trial two
best supports this claim although it
doesn't do it so strongly so i would say
trial
trial two
and that is because the 25
that
warmed
warmed up that is group three
group
three
were
able
on average
to
squeeze more in a minute to squeeze
more
in the minute and then
group
four that didn't warm up
all right let's do another question here
so here we're told students were asked
to design a lab that investigated the
relationship between exercise and heart
rate
heart rate was determined by recording
the pulse rate in beats per minute the
students hypothesized that increased
exercise results in an increased heart
rate the class results for the
experiment are shown in the graph below
and then they say which statement is
best supported by this graph and we're
given four choices so pause this video
and see if you can answer this on your
own
all right now let's go through statement
by statement statement one before
exercising the average pulse rate was 65
four minutes after exercising the
average pulse rate was 65. so let's see
before exercising the average pulse rate
was 65. so before actually this is time
period right over here and it does look
like
over most of that time period the let me
just in red it does look like that is
reasonably that is roughly true it looks
like the average pulse rate was 65 but
now let's read the second part of the
statement four minutes after exercising
the average pulse rate was 65 as well
four minutes after exercising what's the
average pulse rate well it sure isn't 65
it looks closer to being maybe
135 not 65 so we could rule this one out
after four minutes of exercising the
average pulse rate was 120 let's see
so this is when the exercise starts
after four minutes the average pulse
rate was 120. no it looks like it was
like 1
135 or something like this so this is
already looking fishy two minutes after
exercising the average pulse rate was
120. so two minutes after exercising the
average pulse rate actually seems closer
to about 90. so both of those look fishy
i'll rule that one out
while exercising the average the highest
average pulse rate was 150 before
exercising the average pulse rate was
65.
so let's see while exercising the
highest average pulse rate happens right
over there and that does indeed look
pretty close to 150 so this part's
looking good before exercising the
average pulse rate was 65. we already
talked about this period right over here
so this is looking good i'm liking this
choice but let's see choice four
two minutes before exercising the
average pulse rate was 80. so two
minutes before exercising this is when
we start exercising and each of these
hash marks is a minute so two minutes
before the average pulse rate was not
80. so that's false two minutes
after two minutes of exercise the
average pulse rate was 140 after two
minutes the average pulse rate was also
not 140. so both of those statements are
not correct so i like statement three
that's the one that seems to be backed
up by the data here